[Music]
on this Thursday night the search for
hostages held by Hamas we put all the
data on a geolocation map inside the
volunteer team of high-tech experts
dedicated to finding them frayed nerves
among people living on the Israel
Lebanon border as gazin keep waiting for
the aid they've been promised I talked
to a Canadian father of five they had
run out this water examination into a
lack of competition the consequences for
consumers and how to fix it plus they've
blazed a trail on the rink thank you so
much for this incredible award High
honors for Canada's king and queen of
ice
dancing global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us tonight there is still no
sign of desperately needed humanitarian
Aid getting into Gaza which has been
under an Israeli siege for days the US
Secretary General on a visit to Egypt
today called for an immediate ceasefire
so that a sustained supply of food water
and medicine can get
in he says rapid unimpeded access to
Gaza is essential in the north Rescuers
work to dig out an entire family after
an air strike at the jabalia refugee
camp gaza's interior Ministry says at
least 18 people were killed
there further south the so-called safe
zones where Israelis told Gaz and to go
are not safe either the gazan health
authority says at least 12 people were
killed dozens injured after air strikes
in gaza's second largest city Israel
says it is targeting Hamas Fighters not
civilians and today Israel's defense
minister met soldiers near the Gaza
border whoever sees Gaza from afar now
will see it from the inside that is a
promise he told them whether it's real
or rhetoric it's a reminder Israel's
government vows to annihilate Hamas in
Gaza also inside Gaza are hostages taken
by Hamas when it attacked Israeli kutzas
in towns on October 7th Israel says
there are at least 200 of them including
It is believed these two Canadians Jeff
simple begins our coverage tonight with
a search to find the hostages she's
there and she's dying slowly
painfully abda adar's grandmother's
Community was among the first to be
attacked by Hamas gunmen when the
Israeli military finally took back
control of the area hours later they
found her grandmother's house empty then
Adar saw this video on social
media that's her grandmother 85-year-old
yafa on a golf cart driven into Gaza by
Hamas with you know people celebrating
and um having a party with my kidnapped
grandmother like she's a kind of a
trophy and and um that's how we found
out Israel's military says yafa is one
of around 200 Hamas hostages but images
like these on social media could offer
vital Clues to help bring them home our
mission is to to save life rapael Franco
used to be in charge of the Israeli
government's cyber security and now runs
a private firm but since the Hamas
attack he's leading a team of 40
techsavvy volunteers redeploying their
cyber skills to find the hostages we got
the pictures from the families
themselves first they collected
photographs of the missing then used
facial recognition technology to scan
hundreds of thousands of images posted
on social media following the attack we
saw a lot of a lot of videos from Gaza
street so far they've matched more than
50 hostages with images on social media
including Ziva Bud's boyfriend Elia this
is the photo from the couple was
attending a music festival when Hamas
started firing into the crowd she
escaped by pretending to be dead her
boyfriend was taken prisoner later she
saw his photo on social media
identifying him as a hostage in Gaza I
can't say that I'm happy but uh it's G
me a little bit o besides providing hope
that they're alive Franco's team also
logs each photo's geolocation and
provides the details to the Israeli
military he says the hostages have
appeared all over the map we see a
civilian people in a tunnel we see a
civilian people on the main road we see
a soldier it's unprecedented we never
faced anything like that before this
former head of counterterrorism for
Israel's intelligence agency says the
expected hostage rescue operation will
be more daunting than any faced before
because we know for sure there are in
different different places uh with even
being held by different uh uh
organizations some of them are even
being held by locals among the presumed
hostages these two Israeli Canadians
including Judy Weinstein hagy from
Toronto making puppets is my favorite
hobby in her YouTube videos she
discusses her passion for puppet making
and poetry it's a nightmare it's crazy
really her daughter says Judy has long
been an advocate for peace she's now
dreading what comes next and it's it's
just it makes me so angry that I even
need to think about hurting somebody
just to get my mom back and I know my
mom wouldn't want that you know it's
just it's really it's just
heartbreaking really as for adva adar's
grandmother the 85-year-old was already
in poor health and without access to her
medication her family expects that after
12 days in captivity any rescue mission
is already too late Donna Jeff in
Jerusalem thanks the federal government
is now warning Canadians to avoid all
travel to Lebanon because of the
deteriorating security situation and
concerns Israel's conflict with Hamas
could spread it's also warning Canadians
who are there to consider leaving well
commercial flights are still available
Israel is watching not just Gaza but its
northern border with Lebanon today there
were more Rockets fired towards Israel
from Lebanon Israeli forces responded
with shelling Crystal ganing and
photojournalist Barry dony were near
that border today if it is happened
we're in trouble all in trouble Lebanon
Israel Syria the whole region in trouble
Syria is to the right Lebanon to the far
left and we're standing in Israel the
landscape is breathtaking and blood has
been shut across it Kamal abuat has
family and fears another war with
Lebanon you lived a long time in Canada
yeah have you considered just going back
to Canada well I'm waiting to to leave
yeah yeah I'm waiting to leave Israel is
positioning more soldiers and weapons
along the northern border every day and
checkpoints are appearing since the
deadly incursion by Hamas in the South
and Israel's declaration of war Rockets
have been firing
North Sirens ring out daily followed by
thunderous claps and fiery streams of
light in the sky sites we saw first and
on kubot snil part of the community is
only a few hundred meters from the
Lebanese border we can hear it really
really yeah yeah we can hear it maybe
we'll change our walk towards the house
which is much safer
and and everyone has a safe room and we
also have bomb shelters there are also
trenches to protect the kots the
majority of people have been sent away
among those who remain are heavily armed
members there's a team of people which
are get called by the Army and they have
also rifle and equipment and everything
to defend ourselves from the moment
Global News arrived on the kibuts
explosions could be heard
nearby several towns were fired on from
the direction of Lebanon including kirat
Simona Israel's Ambulance Service says
three Israelis were injured including a
child Hezbollah has threatened to enter
the war opening a second front if C on
by their Iranian backers in the town of
bukata Nima samara's restaurant is empty
but her family has been cooking so they
can store away food evacuation orders
are expanding in the region but she
tells Global News she won't go this is
her home but there is a shelter she can
use if she needs it is is it close
enough to run to is it oh it's two
minutes 2 minutes okay across the north
people are either preparing to shelter
in place or they're leaving in the last
week and a half Israel Defense Forces
say five of their soldiers have been
killed Hezbollah reports losing 13 of
its members Juan reuter's journalist was
also killed reporting on the Lebanese
side of the border the people I spoke
with say they know the situation in the
north border region can change in a
minute Donna all right crystal ganing
thank
you Britain's prime minister has
followed the American president to the
region Rishi sunak met with Saudi
Arabia's Crown Prince Muhammad bin
Salman tonight sunak is on a whirlwind
mission to try to ease tensions in the
Middle East sunak also stopped in Israel
telling prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu he wants Israel to win this
war but that Israel's right to defend
itself must be in line with
international law Redmond Shannon
explains an arrival befitting a country
at War Rishi sunak is the third G7
leader to visit Israel since since it
declared war on Hamas very good to see
you I'm sorry about the circumstances
first meeting with President Isaac
Herzog whose father former president Kim
Herzog served in the British Army in the
second world war you've come to visit
Israel in our darkest hour 8 years ago
prime
minister the Civilized World stood with
you in your darkest hour this is our
darkest hour prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu in invoking Winston
Churchill's words too something Ukraine
has also done to encourage British
support during a war we will stand with
you in solidarity we will stand with
your people and we also want you to win
Britain has deployed warships and
aircraft to the region in support of
Israel but sunak also stressed the need
to reduce the suffering of the people in
Gaza I welcome your decision yesterday
that you took to ensure that Roots into
Gaza will be opened for humanitarian Aid
in Saudi Arabia Crown Prince Muhammad
bin Salman told sunak he regards the
killing of people in Gaza to be a
heinous crime ahead of this delicate
trip the UK had not said who it thinks
is at fault for the hospital blast in
Gaza City this month Saudi Arabia posed
talks on normalizing relations with
Israel meanwhile Britain's foreign
minister is in Egypt before heading to
Turkey and Qatar part of a wider atic
Dash among Regional and Western leaders
to try and deescalate a situation that
so many are worried could spin out of
control Redmond Shannon Global News
London about that hospital bombing in
Gaza Israel insists it wasn't them that
it was a misfired rocket from inside
Gaza the US has sided with Israel on
that other experts say it's too early to
make a conclusive determination here's
what Canada's prime minister said
today we are taking the
necessary time to look
carefully at everything and rapidly of
course before we draw any final
conclusions about what happened the Gaz
and health Ministry says at least 471
people were killed today us intelligence
claimed that number is likely anywhere
between 100 and 300 Global News has not
been able to verify either claim US
President Joe Biden addressed the
American people from the Oval Office
tonight he linked Israel and Ukraine the
US is pouring billions of dollars into
defending both countries and Biden made
the case for why he believes it's vital
to America and the world that both
countries are supported and succeed
Jackson prco was listening
Jackson Donna Biden's point is that us
leadership is what holds the world
together and so he spoke of both Ukraine
and of Israel in similar terms saying
that these are democracies that are
under threat and need report from the
United States of course it's worth
remembering that he's the only president
in modern history to visit two active
War zones neither of which is under Us
control his announcement tonight is that
he's calling on Congress to approve
nearly $100 billion doll in Aid split
between Israel Ukraine as well as
towards Taiwan and the US border and
really he addressed the question that
many Americans may be wondering which is
why does this matter to Americans you
know history has taught us that when
terrorists don't pay pay a price for
their Terror when dictators don't pay a
price for their aggression they cause
more chaos and death and more
destruction Biden also said he is deeply
aware of the tent situation in the
Middle East and he is drawing a careful
line to separate Hamas from ordinary
Palestinians speaking out both against
anti-Semitism and islamophobia Donna his
big fiscal ask though faces a real
hurdle in Congress because there's still
no speaker meaning that P passing a bill
to provide that funding to those
countries simply can't happen and Donna
right now there's no path forward on
electing a speaker so this is all
effectively stalled just a big ask right
now okay Jackson prco in Washington
thank you there is an update on Canada's
strained relationship with India
Canada's foreign affairs minister says
41 Canadian diplomats and their families
recently left India after the rift of
the murder of a Canadian six separatist
leader in BC in June India was stripping
the staff of their diplomatic immunity a
unilateral revocation of diplomatic
privileges immunities is contrary to
international law it is a clear
violation of the Vienna convention on
diplomatic
relations and threatening to do so is
unreasonable and
escalatory coming up hundreds of
Canadians stuck in Gaza we hear from a
former
calgarian no one has been able to get in
or out of Gaza for 13 days now and
Israel's Siege has starved it of fuel
food water and Medicine among the more
than 2 million Palestinians there are at
least 378 Canadians including Mansour
Schuman with his wife and five children
they moved to Gaza from Calgary last
year I spoke to him earlier from
Southern Gaza and started by asking him
how his family is
coping my family and I have worked four
times over the last 13 years and uh
right now um uh we've been separated uh
over the last um 72 96 hours um um the
last I spoke to my family U they had run
out of water
and they spent a day in the forest and
they were able to find a well nearby
stay and they were able to some of their
supply uh food rations are running
can you tell me a little bit about your
children I understand they're between
the ages of four and
16 how are they so when I was with them
few days back um my younger two Mariam
and ibraim six years old and four years
old they they keep hearing the buzzing
sounds of the Drone to this guy and that
they can't sleep because of and whenever
uh
a drone suicidal drone hits or an F16
bomb hits in the vicinity and the
building
shakes um My Little Child Omar 10 um
he's asking a lot of questions like
analytical um questions why questions do
you have any answers for them we try to
give them honest answers explaining to
them the situation uh kids are very
smart especially in this age of social
media
exposure they are very aware and I
believe honesty is the best solution
with brutal honesty my eldest two
daughters are 16 and 14 AA
and um they're very smart and they try
to help as much as they can in caring
for the kids and their mom and the other
children in the household but at times
they just sit in the corner and just cry
yeah I imagine you I understand you
moved to Gaza last year from
Calgary uh there's nothing that could
have prepared your children for the
horror that they find themselves in yeah
we moved a year and a half ago uh we had
a family emergency on my wife's side but
we never expected something like this
what's happening is
pilation what would you like Canada's
government to know about your situation
what would you like Canada to do for you
we need the boarders open possible for
the state and then the borders need to
be open whoever wants to go out come in
Canadians or not if you know people
don't feel safe in whatever country
they're in they should have the right
to so
um in the medium term definitely a
seized fire and an end to this war with
a political solution will definitely
help man Schuman and Gaza thank you so
much for speaking with us thank you so
much for your
still ahead why there's less competition
in Canada's economy than there used to
[Music]
be Canada's competition Bureau has
released its first highlevel look at
competition in our economy using stats
Canada data from over a 20-year period
it found large corporations were not
being challenged by smaller competitors
and profits and price markups increased
David Aken looks at how that impacts
affordability for
consumers it's the big mergers that get
the headlines like Rogers takeover of
its Telecom competitor Shaw or more
recently accusations that big grocery
store chains have too much Market power
but a first ofit kind study by the
federal competition Bureau finds it's
much more than that that competition is
weakening across a broad range of
Industries as a result consumers and
businesses have seen fewer of the
benefits of a competitive economy
namely lower prices greater choice and
more Innovation this is a really big
problem to our pocketbooks it's a PO
problem to our prosperity the federal
government has a bill before Parliament
which would give the competition Bureau
more power to monitor Industries such as
the grocery store chains and it would
change the rules used to measure if a
merger should be allowed this is going
to give more Tools in a toolbox to make
sure that we can give more power to the
competition Bureau the minister
responsible Fran Leep champagne thinks
more can be done the real answer to
affordability is to create more
competitive pressures experts blame
years of increasingly complex and
burdensome government regulation that
smaller companies simply cannot navigate
the irony is that it used to be
regulations were there to protect
citizens now they're protecting oopes
because new entrance can't afford the
cost and it's not just a problem the
federal government alone can fix experts
like Senator Deacon say provinces and
municipalities must also overhaul their
regulations to help increase competition
and lower prices Donna okay David aen
thank
you enshrined forever next the athletes
awarded Canada's highest sporting
honor they are Canada's best and today
an illustrious group of athletes was
inducted into the Sports Hall of Fame
nine people including martial arts
fighter George St Pierre and Canadian
curlers the Furby four were were honored
at a ceremony in Quebec it was these two
who stole a
show Tessa virtue is Scott
[Applause]
Meyer in their 22-year career the ice
dancers won a record setting five
Olympic medals three of them gold
they've also won three World
Championships and eight Canadian
national
titles who would have guessed that when
we held hands in silence and skated
around the perimeter of the Ilderton
Skating Club 27 years ago it would lead
to a Hall of Fame induction and oh man
we had a fire our eyes would meet on the
ice and it would take us to another
world our passion for skating and for
skating with each other would ignite and
the feeling was way better than anyone
sorry to tell you this than any
spectator had ever thought that they had
witnessed the pair retired in 2019 they
say they're optimistic about the future
of Canada's Sports landscape that is
global national for this Thursday I'm
Don freezen tonight's here at Canada is
Capel Saskatchewan thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
[Music]
byebye